[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de face aux territoires sur tv5monde en
direct avec nos partenaires de ouest
france de nice matin de france antilles
de centre france la montagne et de 20
minutes une émission d'analysé analyse
de la configuration politique ce matin
revenir sur cette semaine très agitée
politiquement et puis analyser aussi
l'intervention du président de la
république hier soir sur les écrans
puisqu'il intervenait à 20h à la
télévision mais deux invités pour tenter
de banaliser de regarder cette situation
ce matin et bien c'est bruno cautrès
bonjour bienvenue à tv5monde vous êtes
un habitué vous êtes politologue
chercheur au cnrs au cevipof et le
centre d'études de recherches politiques
de sciences po je le dis une fois et
puis enseignant à sciences politiques
aussi et puis sylvain courage bonjour
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
rédacteur en chef à l'ops on disait
avant le nouvel observateur moi j'aimais
bien mais on vous dit que l'ogs avec une
magnifique une d'emmanuel macron ce
matin dans l'obs le président relatif
comment il va devoir composer avec la
nouvelle assemblée c'est toute la sphère
de cette émission ce matin alors qu est
ce qu a dit le président de la
république hier soir de quoi at il parlé
aux français et bien on va écouter
emmanuel macron qui s'était invité à
parler aux français hier soir à 20
heures la plupart des dirigeants que
j'ai reçus ont exclu l'hypothèse d'un
gouvernement d'union nationale
laquelle d'ailleurs n'est à mes yeux pas
justifié ce jour
alors ce qu'a dit le président de la
république pour nous contrer son démarré
par vous est-ce que ça parle aux
français ou est-ce que ça parle aux
partis politiques et à l'establishment
en gros est ce qu'il a été cinquième ou
quatrième république
entre les deux entre les deux c'est vrai
que ça ça parle essentiellement au monde
politique ce dont il a parlé hier il
faut rappeler quand même que plus d'un
français sur deux s'est abstenu aux
élections législatives donc on part
quand même d'assez d'assez loin du point
de vue d' accrocher l'attention des
français à ces questions de de majorité
de comment construire une majorité
néanmoins je crois que ça intéresse les
français de savoir surtout où en est le
chef de l'état on vient de réélire
emmanuel macron le 24 avril et de
n'avons pas toujours ou encore
aujourd'hui une vue extrêmement clair
sur les grands objectifs le calendrier
il ya une intrigue est une énigme pour
beaucoup de français depuis depuis cette
élection emmanuel macron a été réélu une
majorité de français ne souhaitait pas
que ce soit marine le pen qui soit la
présidente de la république et pourtant
ça n'a pas réglé à la fois la question
de pourquoi un deuxième mandat d'
emmanuel macron ça n'a pas réglé les
grandes questions de la crise
démocratique française n'a pas réglé la
question des grandes attentes des
colères sociales peut rentrer d amertume
tout ça donc voilà je suis pas sûr que
le chef détails complètement éclaircies
tout ça hier sylvain courage alors
pourquoi une intervention à 20h à la
télévision question timing bah oui il
fallait quand même qui se replace dans
sa position institutionnelle essayé
d'apparaître un peu comme l' arbitre au
dessus de la mêlée et la mêlée confuse
et les c'est vrai que les contours de
son deuxième mandat sont très floues
donc c'était une intervention un peu
technique le relevé de la situation une
autre est en cible par les français
difficilement parce que assez rapide en
fait je pense qu'il il voudrait surtout
que les français ne s'inquiète pas trop
c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il a fait
bref et sobre comme s'il s'agissait un
peu de minorer l'événement et la crise
politique il a même fait je sais pas si
c'est un lapsus ou si c'est volontaire
il a prétendu qu'il lui manquait 30
députés pour pour atteindre la majorité
janvier quand mal oui or ces 50 donc ça
je pense que ça c'est révélateur de la
volonté d'apaiser d'atténuer le choc
alors ses fans vernet rédacteur en chef
à far ouest france et qui est directeur
de la rédaction du bureau parisien de
ouest-france va nous rejoindre sur ce
plateau dans un instant pour continuer
cette analyse avec nous
[Musique]
bonjour stéphane bern et mon jour avec
nous ce matin depuis rennes françois
xavier le francky rédacteur en chef de
ouest-france lui à son analyse toute
particulière de la situation on l'écouté
on vient à vous après il faudrait
peut-être que les françaises et les
français que les commentateurs se
mettent d'accord lorsque la majorité
était pléthorique c'était le cas de la
précédente mandature mandature on disait
finalement c'est un parlement godillot
l'assemblée nationale ne sert à rien
elle voit de ce qu'on lui dit de voter
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus le cas la
majorité n'est plus pléthorique et mon
alim attention la france va devenir
ingouvernable
est-ce qu'on n'est pas en train de
redécouvrir finalement avec ce qui vient
de se passer les joies du débat
parlementaire la richesse l'importance
essentielle du débat à l'assemblée
nationale au sénat au parlement est-ce
qu'on n'est pas finalement en train de
re de re découvrir la vraie démocratie
qui consistent entre personnes
d'opinions différentes qui consiste à
discuter à essayer de trouver des
compromis a essayé de se mettre d'accord
dans l'intérêt du pays stéphane bern et
j'aimerais vous entendre sur la question
françois xavier le franc est ce qui peut
sortir quelque chose de positif pour la
démocratie de 7 ce chaos apparent à
votre avis
je dois dire que j'aimerais beaucoup
croire dans cette histoire parce
qu'officiellement qui ne voudrait pas
entendre cette histoire que nous sommes
une démocratie vivante avec du débat de
la confrontation mais dans le même temps
et votre alimentaire et dans un même
temps je suis extrêmement intrigué qu'on
puisse dire dans la france de 2020 deux
qu'on est en train de redécouvrir la
démocratie quel message catastrophique
ça passe aux français
et aux européens voilà ans débute le 21e
siècle en découle la démocratie donc
voilà il ya un petit souci est par
ailleurs il ya un petit souci sur les
variables systémique au fond on a un
système semi-présidentiel sa dimension
s'est renforcée depuis le quinquennat on
n'est pas à la république d'allemagne on
n'est pas l'italie non plus et c'est pas
exactement transposable sylvain courage
le message du président de la république
qui arrêtent est censée rendre les
choses plus claires est ce que c'est le
cas est-ce que vous avez compris ses
intentions non il a failli là bas il n'a
pas clarifié réellement son projet
politique il a renvoyé plus tôt la balle
dans le camp de ses adversaires et c'est
là peut-être que le débat peut être
décevant c'est à dire que on est dans
une sorte de querelles de fausse
politesse après vous après vous dit
l'opposition clarifier votre votre
projet monsieur le président et à la
raison à l'opposition il quand le
président dit dites moi sur quoi est ce
que vous êtes prêts à voter contre
sochaux comment les uns et les autres
sur place pour négocier et l'opposition
dit banon
mondiale est prêt à changer dans
certaines archaïsme dans la culture
politique française c'est que justement
on en reste dans cette division étanche
alors que dans d'autres pays on arrive à
surmonter
ses différences et donc à respecter
l'adversaire pour dialoguer il faut
avoir institué un interlocuteur c'est
pas le cas encore c'est pas le cas
est-ce que culturellement la france est
prête pour ça bruno cautrès les
allemands les italiens savent le faire
je pense que culturellement l'idée qu'en
démocratie on débat on confronté qu'à la
fin est une règle qui permet de trancher
pour savoir où est ce qu'on va tout le
monde est d'accord là dessus en français
vit évidemment par contre il ya des
variables qui sont des variables
institutionnels le président allemand et
aide au suffrage indirect le président
italien aussi mais ils ne présentent pas
un programme d'action socio économique
il présente des mesures d'unité
nationale ce qu'il incarne véritablement
dans d'autres pays européens en est lui
le seul président le chef de l'état est
élu au suffrage direct mais sans avoir
les pouvoirs du président français est
donc là on a on a une vraie ding sert
comment faire entrer en rond dans un
carré et emmanuel macron est élu sur un
programme il est il il est légitime mais
aussi portière le périmètre les
discussions c'est bon c'est mon
programme on a d'autant plus
l'impression d'être dans là parce que
quand on écoute les représentants des
différentes oppositions on se dit que
tous considèrent que discuter ou
chercher à faire des compromis avec le
pouvoir exécutif serait une sorte de
compromission que n'accepterait pas
leurs électeurs ce qu'ils ont raison ils
ont en partie raison parce que aucun pro
qu'aucune formation politique ne vient
de faire campagne sur le thème je vous
présente des propositions mais je vous
préviens au lendemain de l'élection
elles peuvent être amendés elles peuvent
être retouchée en fonction des
discussions du jura avec d'autres
formations politiques personne a fait
campagne sur ce thème est le résultat de
ça c'est quoi c'est que la france est
vraiment ingouvernable de fait on a
l'impression qu'on est encore un petit
peu en 1788 toujours c'est à dire que
s'il faut trouver les voies de
d'instituer cette ce dialogue cette
discussion démocratique est on avec une
longue histoire de conflit en fait très
violent autour de ce coin alors on peut
espérer qu'enfin on va on va le résoudre
mais vu la lente mais comment comment on
commence combat et il faut dissoudre il
faut qu est ce que la dissolution c'est
un petit peu le divorce donc c'est pas
forcément dès lors qu'il peut t'il la
faire tout de suite non non trop tant il
est évident qu'une dissolution serait
très coûteuse pour lui si l'asile et
s'il a choisi trop tôt il faut il
faudrait que le pays soit vraiment
bloqué et qu'on puisse établir la
responsabilité de l'opposition dans ce
blocage on va écouter regarder dessinée
chaunu devant nous qui est collaborateur
de ouest france et qu'à une question à
nous poser sous forme de dessin regarde
on écoute
bonjour il se rêvait de gaulle et le
voici
rené coty c'est le grand retour du
fantôme de la quatrième république
à trop vouloir enjamber les élections
bien le président se retrouve avec une
jambe dans le plâtre et les républicains
refusent pour l'instant de jouer les
béquilles tel un empereur romain jean
luc mélenchon a proposé de constituer un
groupe du ps à l'assemblée nationale
mais ses partenaires le monde et au
baryton chars et l'attelage s'est
disloqué voici ma question
toute la colère qui pourraient se
déverser dans la rue ne se rappelle pas
contenue par cette nouvelle assemblée
nationale
est ce que la pression va retomber
monsieur bah disons que la
responsabilité pourrait être plus
partagés puisque on a vu par exemple si
on se réfère à la crise des gilet jaune
finalement les oppositions prenait parti
pour la rue et laisser l'exécutif seul
en première ligne dans les circonstances
actuelles si un tel mouvement se
déclenchait on voit que quand même
probablement la responsabilité serait
plus collective et ça obligerait je
pense à la cocotte-minute
à fonctionner est ce qu elle peut
fonctionner mieux du fait qu'elle a
aussi changé assez fondamentalement il
ya un peu moins de femmes que lors de la
précédente législature mais il ya des
profils socio culturel beaucoup plus
variée est ce qu'on n'a pas une
assemblée qui ressemble beaucoup plus
politiquement culturellement et
socialement à ce qu'est la france
aujourd'hui politiquement
incontestablement par rapport à 2017 et
sociologiquement sociologiquement il ya
quelques améliorations ça reste une
assemblée nationale dominée par les
catégories supérieures les classes
moyennes supérieures ça suffira mais
voilà ces sucres amable il ya des choses
intéressantes des profils nouveaux et
surtout du renouvellement générationnel
des candidats jeunes ont donné des élus
très jeune c'était des chacun de l'ue 17
ans déjà le cas mais là il ya quelque
chose de deux confirmé stéphane bern est
alors la grande absente un de
l'intervention du président de la
république hier soir 7 elisabeth porn
qu'on va écouter rend l'écouté
d'isabelle board
la situation est inédite
jamais l'assemblée nationale n'a connu
une telle configuration sous la vème
république
mais ce vote nous devons le respecter et
en tirer les conséquences
voilà elle faisait cette déclaration
depuis matignon dimanche soir où est
elle passée n'était même pas dans
l'intervention d'un prêt public même pas
si c'est la bonne question effectivement
tout le monde a remarqué qu'elle n'avait
pas été cité c'est rarissime que le
président de la république donc ces
régionales il l'a pas oublié il ne l'a
pas oublier évidemment n'imagine pas que
c'est possible qu'il est qu'ils aient
oublié mais effectivement comme la
question de son équation personnelle à
elisabeth baume sa capacité à mettre en
oeuvre cette situation à être la
personne qui qui effectivement va
arriver concrètement à faire ses
alliages nouveau c'est une vraie
question qui se pose et on n'a pas vu
pour le moment la première ministre bien
à l'aise dans ce rôle le président de la
république a refusé sa démission hier
est ce que vous pensez qu'elle peut
sauter quand même à terme c'est janvier
1er les dans une position de fusible
c'est clairement ça la difficulté pour
elle je crois qu'elle est pendu au
téléphone pour essayer de rallier
quelques députés divers droite divers
gauche pour essayer de montrer que
qu'elle peut être utile en fait elle
elle va passer le baptême du feu très
vite si
emmanuel macron constate qu'elle est
capable de créer ces majorités d'action
elle restera c'est stop ou encore aider
et dès que ça dès que le système se
grippera elle peut sauter quand le
président de la république hier inédit
qui lui manque une trentaine de députés
on disait tout à l'heure c'est un lapsus
mais parce que ça veut pas dire qu'il en
a déjà 15 ans à paul alors il y à dia
des informations dans ce sens oui mais
c'est peut-être le moyen hilal en quels
moyens il a c'est du débauchage
individuel
c'est quoi les moyens la présidence à la
fois je pensais
d'eux de flatter en chacun des députés
de dire mais mes yeux une belle aventure
à jouer il ya quelque chose
d'extraordinaire peut-être de laisser
miroiter l'accès à certaines
responsabilités sait-on jamais c'est
quand même l'appel à la politique
effectivement moi je ne pense pas que
c'était une erreur de calcul il a perdu
cédric villani à un moment donné et cela
n'a pas été réélu député mais c'était
peu nerfs en mathématiques du chef de
l'état je pense qu'effectivement ça
traduit qui a déjà des déboutés divers
qui sont en train de rejoindre la une de
ouest france n'est pas gouvernée nous
devons apprendre à gouverner
différemment et c'est un sacré programme
merci stéphane bern et donc vous êtes
taux directeur dès rédactions de la
réaction du groupe ouest france à paris
bureau parisien merci à vous dans un
instant denis carot de nice-matin
rentrer sur ce plateau
[Musique]
bonjour denis carot civile boutiques et
directeur éditorial de france antilles
notre partenaire dans cette émission
d'en face aux territoires à une question
à poser depuis fort-de-france on les
écoute et on revient à voix près alors
que la composition des groupes à
l'assemblée nationale est plus que
jamais d'actualité il est une question
qui revient pratiquement après chaque
élection législative si celle de la
création d'un groupe qui rassemblerait
tous les élus ultramarins
on pourrait dire toutes tendances
confondues de manière à peser sur les
questions spécifiques aux outre-mer
est-ce que selon vous c'est quelque
chose qui apporterait davantage de
visibilité à nos territoires voilà c'est
quoi c'est un petit nul ps bruno cautrès
capables qui a pas pu se faire duper par
contre effectivement dans les
territoires ultramarins
alors il ya eu c'est vrai que toute
cette question elle est vraiment
intéressante parce qu'on a vu tout au
long de la de la semaine qui s'est
écoulée tout cette question est ce que
les députés ultramarins qu'avait le
soutien de la nuque qui laissait
entendre qu'il s'inscrirait
ultérieurement dans le groupe de la
nuque et itil comptabilisable avec la
nuque mais c'était tout vent un enjeu
très très important on est aujourd'hui
peut-être sur l'hypothèse la création
d'un logo pour gagner en visibilité faut
quand même rappeler qu'à l'élection
présidentielle beaucoup de territoires
ultramarins ont beaucoup ôté marine le
pen a contre macron aux élections
législatives beaucoup là la nuque avec
l'exception de la guadeloupe mais
effectivement il ya cette question de
gagner en visibilité de donner plus de
visibilité aux
élus ultramarins dans l'assemblée
nationale je suis pas sûr que ça se
règle avec simplement la création d'un
groupe je pense que ça serait bien
davantage à travers un avis un affichage
beaucoup plus fort dans l'action
publique la question des territoires
avec tram à denis carot alors on l'a
très bien vu dimanche les français ne
voulaient pas de donné de majorité
absolue à emmanuel macron s'est
confirmée par un sondage et l'a publié
hier soir qui dit que 71% des français
sont satisfaits de cette situation
est-ce que d'une certaine manière les
français ne regrette pas d'avoir
reconduit emmanuel macron on
l'a dit en démarrant serre qui il a été
reconduit parce qu'on on a éliminé la
possibilité que marine le pen devienne
président donc c'est vrai qu'il a été un
petit peu élu par défaut mais c'est
souvent le cas au second tour d'une
élection on dit toujours qu'on choisit
au premier pied au second on élimine
donc elle a été éliminée il a été
désigné ça ne veut pas dire que il avait
un blanc seing pour appliquer son
programme qui par ailleurs n'était pas
très bien défini donc tout ça a conduit
au résultat qu'on voit aujourd'hui qui
finalement est cohérent effectivement
avec la séquence politique antérieure et
si les français sont contents je dirais
que c'est une excellente nouvelle c'est
une excellente nouvelle
parce que déjà se sont pas mal abstenus
donc si après s'être abstenue ils sont
finalement compensé une bonne ou bonne
nouvelle rappelons-nous commander des
cohabitations les français plébiscitent
et la cohabitation et on voyait de ton
nombreux indicateurs avancés élections
législatives montrant que les français
ne souhaitait pas qu emmanuel macron et
les coudes et trop franches sans doute
que les français percevait qu'un
emmanuel macron réélu avec une majorité
importante à l'assemblée nationale
peut-être qu'il allait vouloir
complètement développer ses projets de
réforme et qui lui renvoyait en rappel
loin derrière vous ce camembert la
sodomie camembert de l'assemblée
nationale élue au fond il ya plusieurs
cohabitation possible donne à la fois
avec la gauche avec la droite avec le
centre c'est une multiplicité de
cohabitation se présente face à cloud
vite beaucoup effectivement à
l'intérieur de la majorité
présidentielle déjà on a vu que les
membres de horizon ce matin j'entendais
la porte pas de d'horizon qui disait ben
nous on a notre approche aussi voilà on
a vu à l'intérieur de la nuque que tout
de suite ces questions et la gouvernance
de fonctionnement interne et collective
de la nuit parce qu'ils sont ces
mécontents denis carot emmanuel macron a
évoqué hier soir les fractures et les
divisions qui expriment des inquiétudes
jusqu'à quel point le pays et il
fracturé est-ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui un
risque d'explosion est doublement
fracturée au plan au triplement au plan
on va dire territoriale fracture
territoriale très important en france on
a bien vu au moment de la crise des jets
des jeunes fracture politique très
importante et fracture démocratique il
ya quelque chose qui s'est détériorée
dans la relation des français au système
démocratique c'est devenu une donnée
absolument structurelles on ne peut pas
continuer comme ça avec ses taux
d'abstention et avec des manifestations
de colère sociale populaire
régulièrement on peut pas s'offrir le
luxe d'une deuxième crise et gilet jaune
en france il s'agissait des grâces assez
dégradée notamment dans les zones
rurales et dans les quartiers populaires
et d'ailleurs il a insisté
particulièrement hier soir
il a cité c'est de ces deux
configurations qu'est ce qui s'est passé
dans ces dans ces territoires mais c'est
ça qui est préoccupant dans la situation
actuelle enfin quand je dis à tous elle
sait depuis quelques décennies
maintenant c'est qu'effectivement il ya
une partie de la population qui est
relégué alors mais cette population
légale est divisé en deux grandes
catégories
effectivement les
populations périurbaines et puis les
populations des territoires justement
qui pâtissent du recul des services
publics et ça on connaît parfaitement
cette situation est-ce que macro a voulu
montrer c'est que ses opposants
n'avaient pas forcément la solution non
plus elle donne car heureusement il ya
le conseil national de la refondation
alors oui emmanuel macron voulait
renouer le dialogue avec les français à
travers ce conseil national de la
refondation qui comprend qu'ils auraient
compris des élus des acteurs locaux et
des citoyens est ce que il est mort né
ce conseil national de la refondation je
ne crois pas s'il ya quelque chose que
j'ai pu observer tout au long du premier
mandat d' emmanuel macron régulièrement
ses qu'emmanuel macro n'abandonne jamais
les idées qui lui tiennent à coeur on
peut savourer un problème si on peut
trouver voilà qu'on peut trouver
régulièrement des éléments qu'on a l'air
de découvrir qui sont déjà dans son
livre programme révolution hier soir il
est une phrase qui est passée assez
inaperçue le chef de l'état dit on va
travailler avec les politiques mais
aussi les forces vives nous tous les
forces vives la société civile nous tous
les conférences de citoyens il n'a pas
du tout abandonné ses deux objectifs
mais ce qu'il peut encore associer les
citoyens aux réformes sachant que
l'assemblée reprend une vraie force ce
qui n'était pas nécessairement le cas
avant sylvain courage à l'intérêt de ce
projet qui est encore assez flou c'est
que justement il réunit toutes les
instances il y aurait l'état à
l'exécutif
la sphère politique et les citoyens
parce qu'on voit bien que la situation
actuelle est langage les trois instances
et est donc l'assemblée peut aussi
comprendre la nécessité de créer des
lieux d'échangé de dialogue avec la
société civile et qui est largement
absente pour l'instant de la scène
puisqu'elle s'est abstenu à 50% ça va
être long cinq ans pour emmanuel macron
oui ça va être long de tenir comme ça
effectivement on n'imagine pas très bien
comment ça peut te dire comme ça si ça
tenait comme ça pendant cinq ans ça
poserait alors à ce moment là une vraie
question forte
profondes structurelles sur notre
système institutionnel déjà je pense
qu'il ya quelque chose qui est en train
de se jouer moi j'ai l'impression que
ces élections législatives c'est un
petit peu comme la première lézardes
importante dans un mur porteur de la
vème république
on sent que des choses se passent
derrière le mur et on voit très bien que
du point de vue des réactions des
insoumis ils sont en train d'avancer
leurs pions la 6ème république arrive la
6ème république arrive c'est ça dont
vous parlez un sommet depuis hier il
faudra une réforme institutionnelle oui
elle est prévue alors la proportionnelle
par exemple peut être une première
proposition d'ailleurs mais qui peut
être utilisé de manière tactique puisque
en principe toutes les oppositions sont
d'accord donc elle devrait faire l'objet
d'un consensus et on voit le prix que ça
pourrait avoir pour l'exécutif et on
attend c'est c'est un piège parce que si
la dissolution ensuite les cartes seront
redistribuées en fonction d'un nouveau
mode de suffrage la une de nice matin
denis carot mais la une de nice-matin
service minimum avec l'allocution
d'emmanuel macron qui restait assez flou
dans ses propos hier soir denis carot
directeur des rédactions du groupe nice
matin son producteur de cette émission
merci beaucoup dans un instant armelle
le goff qui dirige la rédaction de 20
minutes sera sur ce plateau
[Musique]
voilà face aux territoires avec bruno
cautrès politologue chercheur cnrs au
cevipof
enseignant à sciences politiques et puis
sylvain courage rédacteur en chef à
l'ops on disait le nouvel observateur
j'aimais bien ça bonjour alvan le groupe
merci d'être avec nous vous diriger la
rédaction de 20 minutes marine le pen on
va parler d'elle se réjouit elle de son
nombre d'élus rouler coûte dimanche soir
au terme de cette longue séquence
électorale de mise en place des
institutions pour le quinquennat qui
vient le peuple s'est exprimé il a
décidé d'envoyer un très puissant groupe
parlementaire de députés rassemblement
national à l'assemblée
[Applaudissements]
qui devient ainsi un peu plus nationale
ce groupe parlementaire pour marine le
pen vous pensez que c'est une rampe de
lancement pour 2027 alors a pris la
présidence d'ailleurs oui alors on voit
qu'elle est très regroupés par le
résultat parce que ça la relance
politiquement ça sauve les finances du
parti c'était quand même un gros sujet
il ya 24 millions de dettes est là avec
son lancement public elle retrouve de la
portance et donc ça la place
effectivement sur une rampe de lancement
et c'est d'autant plus une rampe de
lancement que sa stratégie depuis dix
ans et de s'institutionnaliser et donc
elle peut jouer un rôle plus responsable
qu'on imagine au parlement et donc
renforcer sa stature présidentielle pour
cette entrée de députés à l'assemblée ce
nombre de députés pourtant donc d'un
parti dont on dit souvent qu'il manque
d'ancrage local comment est-ce que c'est
à s'expliquer ce qui s'est passé avec ce
second tour cet ancrage local en fait
c'est réaliser maintenant on regarde la
carte électorale de marine le pen aux
élections à l'élection présidentielle
dès 2017 et encore plus en 2022 on voit
que dans la france rurale en particulier
voilà c'est un phénomène qui n'est plus
limité au nord-est et au sud-est
pourtour méditerranéen et c'est en ça
que le rassemblement national
aujourd'hui devenu un pilier de notre
vie politique et c'est d'ailleurs en
cela que beaucoup d'électeurs ne
comprennent plus du tout l'histoire du
front républicain
parce que pour eux c'est une donnée
structurelle et permanente de l'erp est
il effectivement c'est intéressant on
voit qu'il a peu joué avec ce second
tour le front républicain enfin de façon
à géométrie variable selon les
circonscriptions comment ça se fait
parce que d'abord on disait le
rassemblement national pour beaucoup
d'électeurs aujourd'hui n'est n'est plus
perçu comme été perçus le front national
de jean-marie le pen à l'époque on va le
dire ou le front républicain s'était
véritablement imposé avec un jean marie
le pen provocateur multi condamné en
justice urnes et que des questions qui
étaient quand même extrêmement grave et
donc là on est dans un tout autre modèle
aujourd'hui justement armelle le goff
bruno cautrès silva courage notre
partenaire du groupe la montagne centre
france cette semaine c'est la république
du centre et alexandre charrier qui est
journaliste dans ce quotidien
à une question à vous poser dans ce sens
en l'écoutent bonjour ma question porte
en fait sur l'attitude qui va être celle
du groupe et rennes à l'assemblée
nationale marine le pen parle d'une
opposition qui serait ferme mais
constructive on voit qu'à traverser
législatives le rassemblement national à
à briser le plafond de verre et on voit
que la prochaine étape aujourd'hui c'est
de démontrer que le rn peut être un
parti de gouvernement crédible
donc ma question est ce que le
rassemblement national est ce que les
députés d'extrême droite vont voter des
textes avec la majorité présidentielle
on pense notamment au pouvoir d'achat
est ce qu'il y a une possibilité
d'avancer ensemble comme l'a dit éric
dupont brest
question assez possible que ça se passe
de cette manière dans sur certains
sujets effectivement le pouvoir d'achat
ou peut-être des questions de sécurité
enfin des sujets qui sont au coeur de la
problématique du rassemblement national
afin que le rassemblement national
puisse attester de son utilité et
pourquoi ça peut se faire c'est parce
qu'il ya un intérêt commun il ya un
intérêt pour le rn à montrer qu'ils sont
devenus un parti de gouvernement il ya
un intérêt probablement parce qu'ils
manquent de députés pour voter mais
c'est différent de compter sur ses voix
pour faire adopter des textes que
d'avoir des voix supplémentaires sur
l'adoption de certains textes ah oui
c'est pas du tout la même chose là il ya
quand même eu des débats cette semaine
assez vif là dessus oui mais globalement
quand même malgré tous ces débats on
voit quand même que il ya une stratégie
plus plus de lots de long terme de
marine le pen et du rassemblement
national c'est effectivement de jouer
maintenant le jeu des institutions alors
n'hésitez l'habilité specta bilité
marine le pen on le sait il ya un point
faible par la manière dont la france les
français la personne qu'est la question
de la crédibilité exécutive et ce cas là
les épaules d'un chef de l'état un jour
d'une chef de l'état ça veut dire
qu'elle est candidate aux prochaines
élections présidentielles alors elle a
dit que c'était pas nécessairement le
cas il ya un petit peu de flou là dessus
mais là c'est vrai que la séquence elle
sort de la séquence 2022 incroyablement
renforcée khalifé une deuxième fois au
deuxième tour en progression en voix
fort succès pour les élections
législatives
elle n'a pas été tuée par eric zemmour
c'est eric zemmour qui est en train
d'être au contraire mise à terre par la
séquence de 2022 donc pour le moment
tout va bien pour marine le pen on a un
autre personnage politique qui à
l'inversé plutôt affaiblissent elisabeth
borne est ce que vous pensez qu'elle
doit faire un discours de politique
générale est ce qu elle doit demander ce
qu'elle va aller demander la confiance
du parlement ce qu'il sent fin de rendu
de l'assemblée pour un discours de magic
général après la question de demander la
confiance là c'est beaucoup plus délicat
parce que dans l'état actuel évidemment
mise en minorité donc elle va peut-être
la jouer comme l'avait fait michel
rocard en 88 un discours sans vote mais
ça va a provoqué une bronca des
oppositions mais elle peut essayer de
faire une sorte de discours de la
méthode comment elle va procéder alors
justement pas lisabeth bornes moi j'ai
une question pour vous quel est le
premier ministre idéal d'union nationale
possible ce qu'elle fait c'est la
question à dix mille de leurs françois
bayrou se voit bien qu'on sort
d'ailleurs très clairement laissé
entendre que lui il se voyait très bien
il a dit pour remplacer les abeilles
mortes il faut une personnalité qui
incarne au plan politique a de
l'expérience donc moi en fait alors
c'est vrai que c'est une équation qui
est quand même très difficile parce
qu'au fond il faut surtout quelqu'un qui
est perçu par les groupes parlementaires
comme quelqu'un de sincèrement qui peut
sincèrement jouer ce jeu de faire
adopter sur certains textes des propos
des projets de loi en respectant ses
adversaires c'est pas évident qu'il ya
dans le casting assez pour le casting a
été très bien décrit par bruno cautrès
donc ça plaide pour un vrai centriste un
centriste historique donc bées roux fait
partie de cette catégorie c'est à dire
des gens qui ont toute leur vie
politique ont essayé de de transcender
ce clivage partisan qui qui structurent
la vie politique française depuis plus
de deux siècles et donc il a il a le
profil est il le seul sans doute pas
parce qu'il a un petit défaut c'est
qu'il est comme il a quand même une une
carrière et qu'il est déjà un peu âgées
peut-être pour le job et puis aussi puis
une folie l'arsenal ite
et il ya des inimitiés aussi quand même
parce qu'il s'est beaucoup opposé à la
droite or il s'agit quand même de
conquérir dès l'aller c'est facile donc
mais personne n'a le profil parfait
alors là je ne sais pas et est-ce qu'au
sein de la majorité il y à un personnage
comme guy carcassonne
qui a permis à michel rocard de gérer le
pays avec une majorité relative ou est
ce que s'il allait conseiller de
matignon à l'époque et c'est lui qui
faisait un boulot dans sa cuisine
parlementaire on n'identifie pas encore
mais c'est un personnage qui serait
effectivement absolument fondamental
serre ça doit être une personnalité
extrêmement respectée sur les bancs de
l'assemblée nationale pour être
quelqu'un qui a la fra connaît
extrêmement bien les institutions le
parlement et qu'ils ne sont une sorte
d'autorité morale dans la dans la parole
fait autorité parce qu'au delà du
gouvernement il ya quand même beaucoup
d'interrogations 6 sur l'entourage des
manuels macron à l'elysée beaucoup de
critiques par exemple d'alexis colère
général de l'elysée qu'est ce que vous
en pensez seulement puisque la toute
toute paysage politique a évolué et donc
là la structure du pouvoir dans au sein
de l'elysée mais elle est forcément
impactées et donc s'attendre à ce genre
est un général de l'elysée emmanuel
mâcon ont dit que voiture le sujet des
retraites par exemple il sans qu'il y
ait eu des frictions on dit qu'il ya des
frictions alors après il travaille
ensemble depuis très longtemps et comme
tout tout binôme qui travaille depuis
très longtemps ce doute qui a beaucoup
de connivence beaucoup de respect mutuel
mais comme tout binôme qui travaillent
ensemble depuis longtemps j'imagine
qu'il ya aussi un moment donné l'un des
deux qui aspire un peu de renouvellement
ce qui prouve qu'il peut y avoir des
frictions c'est qu'il ya des récits et
ce qui cite ce qu'ils étaient parvenus à
faire on
le week end c'est que les journées lien
qui filent n'avait aucune information
sur l débat à l'elysée si déjà la porte
s'entrouvre ça veut dire qu'il ya quand
même des difficultés à une vingt minutes
la une de 20minutes c'est les soldes
puisque elle pourrait repartir on voit
que depuis plusieurs années les sols ne
fonctionnait pas très bien mais là avec
la question du pouvoir d'achat
certains consommateurs qui pourraient
considérer c'est pas être comme une
aubaine et c'est parti pour quatre
semaines merci armelle le goff
directrice de la rédaction de 20 minutes
dans un instant s'il ya un gars y'a de
tv5monde nous rejoindre sur ce plateau
[Musique]
bonjour sylvia garcia nous allons faire
un focus sur la presse étrangère ce qui
se dit de cette situation un peu
curieuse et comment allait commencer
comment toi vous parlez des suisses qui
bon camarade propose des cours de
démocratie aux français je pourrais vous
parler des belges un peu taquin qui
s'amusent beaucoup de l'affolement de la
classe politique française est-ce que
cet affolement vu de france vous
surprend
oui enfin quelqu un affolement un petit
peu franco français on est tellement
habitué à ce que la politique passionne
les français en même temps ce que là que
le que la politique entraîne beaucoup de
débats qui nous semblent insurmontables
etc je pense qu'on est un pays très
politique j'en veux pour preuve la masse
de sondages politiques qui sont réalisés
j'en veux pour preuve la masse de livres
politiques au cours de cette élection
présidentielle et législatives il
suffisait d'ouvrir la porte des
librairies ont été stupéfiés par le
nombre de bouquins politique qui
paraissent ils doivent quand même bien
se vendre à un moment donné donc la
france devait vous même voilà une vraie
passion transmise basions à la politique
à l'éthique et nos voisins européens ont
du mal des fois à comprendre cette cette
passion pour le débat politique français
très intense alors évidemment tout ce
que vous avez dit jusque là été
largement commentée par la presse
étrangère je voudrais qu'on s'intéresse
regard vue d'ukraine les médias se sont
globalement rassurés par le fait qu
emmanuel macron reste aux commandes de
la politique étrangère le journal en
ligne ukraïnska pravda souligne tout de
même que dans l'opposition il va y avoir
des politiciens antioxydantes ou
ouvertement pro russe est-ce qu'ils vont
s'employer à limiter les possibilités
sur ce champ là alors suivons croire les
déclarations de jean luc mélenchon quand
ils s'imaginaient premier ministre il
avait dit que la france parleraient
d'une seule voix et il avait les il
avait donné l'impression de se convertir
à la ligne de l'elysée c'est-à-dire
soutien à l'ukraine avec la possibilité
quand l'ukraine ne souhaitera d'engager
des négociations avec la russie de
poutine et marine le pen a dit la même
chose donc en fait les positions sur ce
sujet ukrainiens ont évolué plutôt
favorablement
azé linski et à l'ukraine qui qui qui
souffrent sous les bombes je crois mais
quel impact aura ce parlement sur la
politique étrangère de la france on dit
toujours que les législatives c'est pas
la politique étrangère un peu comme un
mot oui quand même toujours un peu parce
que quand même la constitution dit que
le chef du vermont d'hui la politique de
la nation donc dans la politique la
nation il ya bien la dimension
européenne et internationale
je pense que beaucoup d'européens se
pose une double question soit manuelle
mâcon c'est au fond sa situation
nouvelle parce que ça va l'amener à se
réfugier à se cantonner dans le domaine
de la politique internationale et
européenne est ce qu'ils vont avoir un
matin aujourd'hui sur alternantes à sion
directive sur la question européenne ou
est-ce qu'au contraire emmanuel macron
va devoir mettre les mains dans le
cambouis de la politique nationale avec
des élections européennes qui arrive en
plus quand ils sont les rocheuses
fiancée avec dans les prochaines heures
d'une très grande très forte séquence
diplomatique internationale le sommet
pour valider la candidature acté la
candidature de kiev dans l'otan ensuite
est ce qui arrive affaibli emmanuel
macron je pense pas que pour le moment
le président français soit perçue comme
affaibli tout le monde sait qu'il ya au
fond des difficultés pour lui pour avoir
une majorité
parlementaire mais ils connaissent aussi
très bien les pouvoirs importants du bar
le du président français et notamment
s'être mastery du domaine réservé sur la
question à l'international boris johnson
lui même en angleterre voilà est aux
prises avec son parti elle ne fait pas
l'unanimité dans son propre camp qu'il
ya deux êtres la crainte du côté des
européens qu'un président français
potentiellement affaibli ça soit une
europe qui stagne une reprise c'est un
problème d'emploi du temps aussi c'est à
dire qu'on l'a vu d'ailleurs c'est une
des explications de la situation
actuelle on a dit le président est
absent il n'a pas fait campagne dans la
présidentielle il a il a voulu en jambes
et les législatives et finalement
voilà il n'a pas pu communiquer avec les
français c'est en partie vrai emmanuel
macron été absorbée par les affaires
internationales la crise ukrainienne et
il sait aussi passionné pour ça et
finalement
il ya peut-être pour lui un choix à
faire maintenant entre bâle et robes
sont mieux ministre ou être présent là
il va falloir qu'ils clarifient aussi
son emploi du temps est ce que son salut
quand même dans cette période un petit
peu compliqué là on voit qu'il va partir
à l'étranger c'est le calendrier qui
veut ça ce que son salut viendra de
l'étranger peut-être dans cette séquence
condé contenu donne une stature que
n'ont pas les autres
acteurs de la de la scène politique
française lance et à ses pratiques de
partir à l'étranger à un moment comme
celui là oui à la fois ça permet au
président de prendre du champ de
réaffirmer effectivement son rôle
tout le monde sait tous les français
savent qu'ils emmanuel là qu'on est un
convaincu de l'europe que c'est son
point fort et donc il serait pas étonné
de voir étonnant de voir quelle que soit
la configuration le politique emmanuel
macron qu'a affirmé pendant toute la
guerre en ukraine sa volonté de passer
une étape sur l'europe de la sécurité et
de la défense il serait pas être
étonnant du tout de voir emmanuel macron
faire des propositions fortes on va
avoir un moment très intéressant qui va
être le passage de témoin de flambeau à
notre pays pour la présence de l'union
européenne et sans doute que emmanuel
macron va en profiter pour faire passer
des messages forts sur sa vision de
l'europe on garde sylvia garcia
rédactrice en chef adjointe de tv5 monde
et on va s'intéresser à ces nouveaux
députés alors une extrêmement
emblématique c'est rachel kéké on l'a
beaucoup vu dans les médias les députés
la france a soumises de la 7e
circonscription du val de marne la voix
des sans voix en l'écoutant j'ai su la
voix des sans voix je suis fan des
chambres femme de ménage agents de
sécurité aides sociales aide à domicile
je suis tous ces métiers invisible alors
tous et betty invisibles sont vraiment
représenté à l'assemblée nationale c'est
une froidure
c'est une figure qui l'incarnent on peut
pas contester sa légitimité à
représenter ce monde ces emplois là
c'est très nouveau c'est la reçut comme
étant des traits je pense que c'est une
france en ce que c'est c'est quand même
très nouveau
là l'assemblée nationale n'a cessé de
s'embourgeoiser
depuis 58 et là il ya un symbole qui
vient alors à l'encontre de ça on est
très loin du sénat bruno cautrès vous en
arrivez oui on est assez loin du sénat
ça c'est sûr mais les sénateurs sont un
peu plus âgés
un peu plus masculin voilà donc on est
on est un peu loin effectivement par
contre c'est vrai qu'elle a quelque
chose d'extrêmement intéressant de voir
des nouveaux visages de nouvelles
figures arrivée à l'assemblée nationale
et c'est vraiment très intéressant parce
que ça montre dans une france où
l'abstention domine ça montre que ceux
qui s'engagent ll est directement issu
d'un engagement très important avant
même d'avoir été candidate aux élections
législatives elle a porté ce combat
contre un groupe hôtelier auquel elle
travaillait sa montre qu'au fond de
l'implication l'engagement avec l'idée
d'être utile et de porter un combat
collectif ça finit par papé et le coeur
de la politique c'est au fond de faire
découvrir que les problèmes que vous
vous attribuez l'épreuve mes problèmes
personnels ne sont pas des problèmes
personnels ils sont les prem politique
c'est ça le message dont elle allait
porter une minute chacun pour conclure
ignorer paf finalement dans cette
nouvelle assemblée deux formes de
députés des députés plus notable des
gens qui sont installés depuis longtemps
qu'ils vont continuer le même type de
comportement parlementaire et puis des
députés comme on vient de le voir avec
rachel kéké qui songe à dire qui colle
plus peut-être à une forme de sociologie
de la france mais qu'il n'est pas
habitué aux joutes parlementaires et aux
systèmes à la mécanique parlementaire
bain et donc on peut espérer qu'il ya un
échange de l'expérience c'est à dire que
une richesse acquise est possible à la
moyenne ces deux mondes
forcément puisque ils vont devoir
travailler ensemble collaborer pour
faire des lois donc probablement à celle
qui va apprendre beaucoup de choses sur
les institutions le fonctionnement du
parlement et l'élaboration d'un texte et
puis j'espère que les députés qui
travailleront avec elles vont aussi plus
sensible à la question de l'emploi et de
l'espoir à bruno cautrès un courage oui
il a raison parce que au fond si nous
canalisons observant la vie politique on
a pas d'espoir que la situation est
compliquée que beaucoup s'abstiennent et
que la vision qu'ont les français de la
politique est trop fait très négative
ça serait désespérant bruno cautrès
politologue chercheur cnrs au cevipof
centre de recherches politiques de
sciences po et puis enseignant à
sciences politiques et puis sylvain
courage rédacteur en chef à l'ops je
remonte recettes une magnifique avec
cette photo les identifie le président
relatif merci à vous de nous avoir aidés
à analyser cette configuration vraiment
très particulière après cette semaine
agitée merci sylvain garcia a très vite
des programmes continus sur tv5 monde au
revoir à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]